si ucrania formalmente informado que ha
establecido dos rutas para las
exportaciones de cereales se trata de
rutas que pasan por polonia y rumanía lo
ha dicho el viceministro de relaciones
exteriores de ucrania dmitro sen y que
recordemos que la disminución de la
producción ucraniana provocada por el
conflicto las dificultades para exportar
los granos que se encuentran en los
silos de los puertos del mar negro por
el bloqueo de rusia y también la
especulación están provocando unas
subidas muy significativas en los
precios de los alimentos que amenazan
con una crisis alimentaria global sin
precedentes de acuerdo con las
organizaciones internacionales esto por
supuesto también afecta a américa latina
por otra parte continúan en ucrania los
combates en el este del país en
particular en las localidades de lichi
sanz y se ver dones que son epicentro de
la batalla del donbass en severodonezk a
las autoridades ucranianas han
denunciado que un ataque ruso
ha afectado una planta química lo que a
su vez ha provocado un gran incendio y
la preocupación allí también es por unos
800 civiles que se encuentran en
refugios subterráneos
precisamente en este lugar